you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
phasing out government support for
fossil fuels and
renewed commitment to nature g7
environment ministers meet ahead of the
leader summit in cornwall next month
of climate crimes we look at why
brazil's environment minister
is under investigation and
creating a living laboratory in the
sussex countryside
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions
now climate and environment ministers
from g7 countries have been meeting
virtually to discuss
issues including the phasing out of the
use of coal
and providing climate finance to
developing nations
it comes ahead of the full g7 meeting in
cornwall next
month and the cop 26 climate summit
which will take place in glasgow in
november
well our science correspondent thomas
moore is here with me
so thomas what's come out of this
meeting
well this is a meeting of the
environment and climate ministers from
the g7 so that's the us
canada uk uh italy germany france
and japan and together they account for
uh 27
of global greenhouse gas emissions so
whatever comes out of this is
significant
and it is really encouraging so they've
agreed to put nature and climate at the
heart of their economic recovery for the
pandemic
uh there will be a commitment to protect
or conserve 30 percent of
land and ocean by 2030 to set
biodiversity targets to uh to tackle
global
deforestation and also to come up with a
financial support package for developing
countries as they adapt to climate
change
but perhaps most eye-catching of all are
these commitments on coal the dirtiest
of
all fossil fuel fuels and they say that
uh they will accelerate their own
transition away from unabated coal and
that's coal power
that doesn't have carbon capture and
storage with it
and bear in mind that some of these g7
countries use an enormous amount of coal
us 27 percent of its power uh still
comes from
uh from coal and germany and japan
switched to coal
uh after the the fukushima nuclear
accident so for them this is going to be
a major step forward but also there is a
commitment to
end the the financial support for
building coal power stations
in third countries particularly in
developing nations and japan has been a
major financer this would leave
china as the only major player in terms
of global finance so again a hugely
significant step
thanks thomas let's take a look now some
of the day's other climate news and
thousands of students in australia have
walked out of school
to protest against the government's lack
of climate action
the school strike for climate
campaigners want more renewable energy
projects
and a plan for net zero emissions it
comes as the government's announced it's
investing
600 million dollars to build a gas-fired
power station
in new south wales
[Applause]
a plastic bag will now cost 10 pence in
england and all businesses will have to
charge for them
the government hopes the new cost will
reduce the number of single-use
bags by up to 80 percent in small and
medium-sized shops
but environmental groups say it doesn't
go far enough they're calling for a
total ban
including on bags for life
[Applause]
campaigners are declaring a nature
emergency for sheffield
several environmental organizations have
joined together
to set up a recovery group to help
restore nature and wildlife
across the city they hope a team effort
will protect
endangered species such as otters curly
birds and hedgehogs
who are threatened with extinction
[Applause]
and one in four drivers say they'll
switch to an electric
or hybrid vehicle in the next five years
that's according to energy regulator
ofgem which is calling for better
infrastructure such as more charging
points on uk
roads to encourage people to make the
switch
this weekend ford are lending an
electric car to every driver in ford
which in
kent in a bid to convince more people to
stop driving petrol and diesel cars
wendy has been driving one of the
mustangs this morning
i firmly believe in the electric cars i
believe
that this is the future my main concern
is the charging points
you know will i be able to charge it at
home if not
how long can i drive the car before i
have to charge it
what is the distance that the car will
actually go on
a full charge one of brazil's most
high-profile politicians is under
investigation for what amounts to
environmental crimes
police searched the home and offices of
environment minister ricardo salas this
week
who's accused along with others in his
ministry of facilitating
illegal timber exports so let's take a
look at how it all started
well jaye bolsonaro was elected as
president of brazil
in 2018. now he's a controversial figure
for many reasons
including comments made about women race
and homosexuality
his handling of the covid19 pandemic and
claims that environmental policy
suffocates the
economy he appointed ricardo sales as
environment minister a move heavily
criticized by
environmental groups sales has
previously questioned deforestation
figures
called the global warming debate
innocuous and criticized
a proliferation of environmental fines
since jaya bolsonaro and ricardo sales
have been in their roles
deforestation rates in the amazon have
risen to record
levels environmental groups say sales
has systematically
dismantled rainforest protection
programs
and overseen a surge in the destruction
of the rainforest
some experts have concluded the
brazilian amazon is now no longer
a carbon sink where the rainforest
absorbs carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere
but is tipped into being a net emitter
of co2 and this has huge consequences
for a world trying to stop global
warming others say brazil is doing what
it can to tackle climate change
the government has committed to reaching
net zero emissions by 2050 and pledged
to double funding
for environmental enforcement efforts
and salis has repeatedly asked developed
nations for billions of dollars to
support
brazil's climate efforts well let's
bring in now
suli arujo from the brazil climate
observatory and also the former head of
brazil's environment agency
welcome to you ricardo salas has denied
any wrongdoing
says that the environment ministry has
always acted reasonably
but how great are concerns more
generally about the effectiveness of
brazil's rainforest protection
programmes
ricardo sales is really an
anti-minister of the environment he
criticizes
all the time environmental policy
environmental legislation
environmental inspection and the
environmental agents uh
also president bolsonaro and the
environment minister
almost daily they legitimize
environmental policy
with their discourses this is really bad
gives a sign that everything can be done
without respecting environmental rules
deforestation for this reason
is has exploded under bosonaro
government
and crime is related to illegal mining
invasion of public lands and the others
have also increased a lot uh
it's important to to to see
that the deforestation generates 44
of the greenhouse gas emissions in the
brazilian case
does the explosion of deforestation in
the amazon
has extremely negative climate climatic
effects jaya bolsonaro would say
that he's pledged for brazil to be
carbon neutral by 2050 and has
recommitted to net zero deforestation by
2030. what would you say to that then
i don't believe in that because they
will not change
their position they have a
they understand that economic growth
demands cutting down forests
they do not incorporate the development
of activities that maintain the efforts
such as the sustainable exploitation of
biodiverse
resources this is a vision for 50 years
ago
in my opinion these problems will
continue
until the end of about bolsonaro
government suli our ujoe
thank you it's it was a pleasure
now let's take you over to our data
dashboard because i want to show you the
figures at the top
of the screen because there you can see
the percentage of electricity in great
britain coming from
fossil fuels from renewable sources and
from nuclear as well
and according to the national grid a new
record has been set in the early hours
of this morning
for the share of wind power in the
generation mix now
early indications are that between 2 a.m
and 3 a.m
wind was contributing 62 and a half
percent
to britain's electricity mix you can see
renewables now accounting for 59
the previous record for wind was 59.9
set in august last year so perhaps some
benefit coming from this wild and windy
weather that we're having at the moment
now kew gardens is world famous for its
beautiful glass houses and critical
science and conservation work and now
its wild botanic garden wakehurst in
sussex
is set to be transformed into a unique
living laboratory
exploring the benefits of a bio-diverse
british landscape
one of the areas scientists will be
focusing on is carbon and how trees and
fungi work together
to capture the greenhouse gas joining me
now is dr justin mode from wake host
he'll be working on the landscape
ecology
program and welcome to you tell us a
little bit more then about this
living laboratory and what you're trying
to achieve from it
what we're trying to do is use the
actual gardens we have in waco
plate as essential labs so we can
understand the interactions between
trees and fungi
and actually start measuring in real
fine detail the carbon and the carbon
uptake trees take
but also into the soil and these areas
are very poorly understood
well yes sir so how much of your focus
while you're
exploring these areas is climate change
i mean it's what we're looking at is the
sort of baseline level of how much
carbon there is
in the uh natural environment and this
is obviously used for offspring and
climate change
so it's going to be important and
government and people are making large
investments in this area
but the understanding in this area is
actually quite poor and tell us a little
bit more about the living landscape what
kind of plants are there
and what else you might learn well we
have a whole suite of plants across wake
up place
from traditional uk woodlands to a
botanic gardens a bit like queue as well
but also have wetland areas so we have a
whole suite of sort of habitats where we
can test
where different amounts of carbon and
carbon fit in that landscape
well doctor justin mode from a windy way
curse thanks very much indeed for
joining us
thank you now today is endangered
species day and to market
wildwood trust have shared pictures of
some of the uk's iconic
but endangered species they include wild
cats
beavers red squirrels hazel dormice and
water voles
one in four wildlife species in the uk
are endangered and at risk of extinction
so charities hope that learning about
these animals will give them a better
chance of
survival and that's it for today's show
but
you can get your climate fix over the
weekend with our podcast and on this
week's episode we discuss
if the technology of the future can help
fight climate change
now that's on climatecast and it's
available wherever you normally get your
podcast from
and on our weekly digital show we go
behind the scenes of our diplomatic
editor dominic waghorn's report
from the place known as cancer alley in
louisiana
that's available on sky news social
channels our app and website
thanks for watching and see you next
week
you